hi everyone
Sal Khan here from from Khan Academy
welcome to our daily homeroom which is
our way of staying in touch it started
with with obviously all the school
closures and social distancing with
kovat but now it's really just evolved
into a an interesting forum to have good
conversations about education and other
things before we get into our
conversation with today's guests that
I'm very excited to be speaking to I
will start with my standard the
announcement or what I always say which
is a reminder that Khan Academy is a
not-for-profit that we can only exist
with philanthropic donations from folks
like yourself so if you're in a position
to donate please think about doing so I
want to give a special shout out to
several corporations that stepped up
especially once they saw that we were
already running at a deficit pre kovat
and that our deficit had grown in order
to support the fact that our traffic was
250 300 percent of normal and we're
trying to accelerate a whole bunch of
programs to to keep everyone learning a
special thanks to Bank of America Google
org 18t fastly and Novartis so thanks to
all of them but I do remind everyone
we're still running at a deficit so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating so with that I'm
really excited to invite our guest
Rachel skipper Rachel there's many ways
to introduce you you are that you are
the head of school for my children's
school that is one way you you run Khan
Lab School which which I helped get off
the ground but you really are doing the
real heavy lifting you and you and the
team there and also I think you have
just a broad background as an educator
you know you were the head of it was it
strategic strategy at Phillips Andover
for many years we worked in admissions
you've worked as a lawyer you've worked
as a strategy consultant so very broad
background so Rachel thank you thank you
for joining us thank you for having me
Sam so a couple of there's a bunch of
stuff you know when we originally
scheduled you know one of the things
that that would be really interesting to
talk about is how Conwell may be a good
place to start just to ground us is
explain to me and to those
watching you know why do you think a
school like Khan lab school needed to
exist or what what was interesting about
it to you that you know you wanted to
become the head of school and then I'd
love to go into how you've been able to
navigate the kovat school closure
situation and then also talk about a lot
of the the environment that we're not
finding ourselves in sure so there are
lots of things that you need a Khan map
school I would say one of the things
that was the most important to me was
this underlying assumption that all
students could achieve at a very high
level and that because we give students
this space and time to really master
material without the outside pressure of
arbitrary letter grades allowing them a
lot of autonomy and the ability to work
with other students and other teachers
the motivation for our students is
really internal it's not pressure from
parents but really the kids are
motivated because they want to learn and
I also think the year-round model for us
is really exciting
so even when parents are interested in
the school and they ask a little bit
about our summer term and what that
means and what the kids be sad that they
don't have summer what I explained to
them is school shouldn't be so bad for
nine months that students eat summer as
an escape but if school is really
exciting for the whole year students are
really excited to come even during the
summer and it helps with things like
knowledge loss and other things that
happen when when schools are just closed
for three months no and obviously I'm
biased here but I can say as a parent
that it's it's strange when and it's a
full-day school so the school day ends
at 5:00 or 6:00 p.m. the kids don't want
to leave and and the Arabs they don't
like breaks when they're sick we kind of
have to say it's it's time to grow that
they try to pretend they're okay it's
the opposite of probably what some other
schools have to deal with when kids are
malingering but our kids they love
and and and what you know what has been
I guess there's a couple things pre
kovat what has been your you know your
kind of take away have some of those
beliefs been confirmed what's been
difficult but I think given the world
that we're in a lot of educators are a
lot of places have struggled with
virtualization or whatever school
closures and then we're going into
another back-to-school season which is
also going to be very uncertain yeah
what's what's your analysis of how KL s
has fared through this school closures
what do you think you y'all have done
that have worked out well and what are
other learnings so I think some of the
things that have worked out well they've
worked out well because their processes
and practices that we've always had and
so for instance things like student
autonomy for our youngest students say
second graders third graders they'll
need with a teacher who's an advisor
they'll meet with that person once a
week for 30 minutes to map out their
week what they're gonna study when
they're gonna study
when they're gonna spend time on passion
projects but we really focus on things
like executive skills in addition to
social-emotional learning but really
those skills that are so important when
people leave school but that most
schools don't talk about or help support
students in developing so even though we
are traditionally a brick-and-mortar
school and right we're not an online
school naturally just some of the
technology that our students use and are
also responsible for in terms of handing
and work tracking their progress when
school moved from the building to home a
lot of our students even the owner once
again had exercised that muscle of
planning out their work handing things
in using an electronic forum and so I
think that's that's been really
beneficial for our students and I think
also for our older students particularly
our seniors we have our first graduating
class coming up we didn't have to have a
whole debate about how
we gonna grade the students if they're
not here we'll use a mastery based
system which means that students can
move forward once they've mastered
material and so what we say it's
effectively sort of a 90 percent of
mastery of all the material so that they
don't have gaps so students were able to
focus on the learning and not oh is this
b-plus can I get it to an a-minus or you
know I'm just not going to show up
anyway because I'm not doing well we
allow students the space to really
achieve and do well right right and I
have to say you know the what's
interesting for anyone if you visit the
school what's unusual or what people
find unusual is you'll even see seven
and eight-year-olds who have a very
clear idea of what they need to do at
any given time and you know even though
it might be associated with me or Khan
Academy a lot of ways it's not a
technology focused school it's about
student agency and collaboration and and
and human interaction and so you see
these kids being able to take that
agency and I know they're there there's
a question from YouTube
adnan abbas khan chaiwallah about you
know what why do you need a kls if you
have things like Khan Academy that kids
could use it whenever they want and I'll
actually take a stab at that the logic
behind founding Khan Academy was I
started founding Khan Lab school is that
kind of kind of me exists and hopefully
you can scale and empower hundreds of
millions or billions of folks but the
existence of tools like Khan Academy
allows us to reimagine what the actual
school day or school structure could
look like and so some of the things that
Rachael talked about you know why do we
have to take off during summers why
couldn't go all year-round can't we get
to a competency-based model can't we
create a world where the students teach
each other where a faculty are able to
co-teach where they're able to do
one-on-one smaller group sessions and so
the whole point of it and why is to
relax cool is so that it can explore
these in and eventually share share with
the world and I have to say Rachel you
know you and and the team at Condon lab
school as a parent it has been amazing
how seamless it has been but and I think
to a large degree because it is y'all
have been reinforcing these ideas of
student autonomous e autonomy agency and
these really personal kind
actions between the teachers and the
students but I think is super powerful
what one question you know there's a
bunch of questions people are asking
about about this coming school year
right you know what do you think is
going to happen broadly is just someone
who observes the education space I know
you talk to a lot of heads of schools
around the country and principals and
how are y'all thinking about it so we're
doing a lot of scenario planning right
and so we are there sort of a scenario
where everything goes back to normal and
we're all in the building as we were
before which is really we put on the
Shelf because that's not likely to
happen and so now we're thinking about
where our students are developmentally
we're at K to 12 so what do our new
five-year olds or kindergarteners what
are they going to need and what kind of
support as students move up through that
chain through senior year how much time
if we're able to can they spend on
campus and then how do we do some of
that teaching remotely and I'd like to
go back to the earlier question about
sort of why do you need a Khan lab
school and it's just because learning is
relational right and one as students
develop they move from this mode to
building a foundation right learning how
to learn habits of mind but content is
important and even though there are a
lot of things that are at a student's
fingertips it's much easier to grow in
your math development if there are
things like times tables that you know
and you can recall instead of having to
look those up every time you have a
question and so the same way if I just
put a piano in a kid's house you know
it's actually helpful for them to have
someone with a deep expertise who knows
kids well to really teach them and build
scaffolding and so the students practice
and then they're eventually able to
learn pieces on their own so I think
what we've discovered even though
everyone is in their own home or
apartment learning is that it's the
community piece that's really
helped and the fact that we know our
students really well we've had enough
time to check in not only with our
teachers but with our families to see
who had the necessary technology and
internet connections at home and who
didn't so that we could make sure that
everyone had what they needed by the
time but sort of school went remote so
for the fall we're doing a mix of sort
of health and wellness and what the
County of Santa Clara is telling us as
possible in terms of physical distancing
maths things like that and then we're
also thinking about where our students
are in terms of what they're able to do
on their own and then we're also
thinking about the social aspects
because even you know the most brilliant
student who probably doesn't need
teachers anymore even though they're
really helpful to help us teach other
students you still need that social
aspect there's still so much about
growing up that is about learning how to
exist with other people and negotiate
and the moments in between classes
there's as much value in there I think
the student says what they're learning
in class so to get to your question Sal
I think we're looking at sort of a
hybrid model of having students at home
having students come to campus when
possible and thinking about how to make
that as seamless as possible so we'll
see and one thing that actually should
defend time to brainstorm on it more but
I'm excited about it because you know
when we started kls I was hoping that a
lot of the school day could happen
outside but now we have a
epidemiological reason for that so I'm
intrigued by how far you mean just a
tree in a hot spot and and you know it's
a people don't realize the word Academy
actually comes from a field where where
Plato used to teach or have Socratic
dialogues outside and then it became his
academies academic so I I'm a big fan
especially if the weather is good even
if
weather's bad frankly I think it builds
character you know the kids are tough
they can handle it it's California we'll
be fine that's that's right and even if
it's not California it's you know we're
meant to be in nature and there's a ton
of questions here about the education
model but I do want to actually broaden
our conversation because I think there's
another obviously what's been happening
with black lives matter with the George
Floyd murder and what I found your
letter to the community I thought was it
it was reflective and it gave justice to
the moment were in but it was also I
found almost strangely hopeful and had a
silver lining to it so I guess one
question that I think a lot of folks are
struggling with especially parents of
young kids are how do we talk about
what's going on in the world well how do
we talk about police brutality racism in
this moment you know is that's an
interesting question I have preschoolers
and so the the conversation I have not
as an educator but as a parent with my
husband is sort of what what do they
already know and how can we best support
them so I'd say for us as an
african-american family one of the
things that we make sure of is that in
terms of the books that we have in the
house that might kids see themselves
represented right and it's not
necessarily books about the civil rights
movement or you know people who broke
barriers but also about kids in Central
Park hanging out with a dinosaur right
or kids who bring a lion to the library
but there's something about an educators
talk a lot about mirrors and windows and
so there's a part of the population
where they see themselves mirrored and
everything right
TV shows games the books that they have
and then they're so kids that only have
windows they're very good at
understanding cultures that are
different than theirs particularly if
they're not in the majority but they
don't see a lot of mirrors and so for us
in terms of to building
are our kids self-worth it's really
about making sure they have as many
mirrors as possible in their day-to-day
lives including schools so you know what
books are in the school library and what
does the student population look like
for older students if I can put my
educator hat back on there have been so
many book lists going around for parents
to read older students to read along
with them stamped is a great book that I
would recommend the new Jim Crow has a
young readers edition and also a
teacher's guide but I also think one
it's important whether you're a parent
or a teacher when you're having
conversations the point isn't to
necessarily we traumatize particularly
your rack of black and brown students so
if you're a history teacher and you're
talking about Emmett Till you don't
necessarily have to show the picture of
him in the coffin right our humanity is
not in our death but you can have a
picture of him when he was a alive a
vibrant young man and the same thing
with the books that are read I think
there's a lot about American history
that people in the US don't know so for
parents what do you know about
reconstruction at the time when African
Americans were governors and Senators
I'm in running towns in addition to
understanding things like the Tulsa race
massacre so it would be an it would be I
think disrespectful for me to at this
point lack hope just in thinking about a
lot of the work of the people who came
before me even in my family my
grandparents my parents
and so I'm for now I'm I'm hopeful but I
know that people have to do work and
another good book the condemnation
blackness I think everyone has to check
through their underlying presumptions
about people and I the one of the things
that brings me the most hope is just
looking at the people who are
demonstrating and protesting it's some
of the most multicultural and I think
there are a lot of coalition's being
built so just the people who are in the
street protesting Blut out police
brutality really focused on anti racism
it's probably the most the most diverse
group of people that this country has
ever seen and it's happening around the
world yeah and what's your advice you
know something I'm struggling at home
especially the younger kids you know you
know you know you know all my kids but
you know azad india or five and and
almost nine years old you know they they
they know something's going on and
they're curious they might even have
seen some of the footage of you know i
hope they haven't seen the footage of
the of the george floyd murder but you
know how do you because there's one of
this the graphic nature of some of it
and some of us like well maybe they saw
at some age maybe they should they
should see it but then there's also a
question of you know for some of them
they're just like wait this makes no
sense at all like why you should anyone
be you know based on their skin it just
doesn't rock with their head and you're
almost introducing the idea of racism
through them i mean i think the reality
is that even though they're young kids
and young kids have a very
well-developed sense of justice they
know it's not fair use we still live in
this country right so there are things
that are just there in the walls they're
systemic that we don't question but that
still color how we interact with people
so one of one of the conversations oh
you know if you want to talk to you kid
about it's just to ask them what they
know what have they heard and i think
people would be surprised by how much
their children have picked up if they
haven't actively had these conversations
in the house just you know kids are
smart and they get by with a lot of
things because they know how to listen
and so I think that you can assume that
kids don't see color right one because
they don't but two there are a lot of
studies that say even when kids are
babies they do so then the question is
is the difference a bad thing or a good
thing and so those are the kind of
conversations that you can have and I
think there's also the conversation
about even sort of the most innocuous
things that that people assume about
different groups of people so can you
have that conversation and be brave and
have you done enough work and study as a
parent to be able to answer some of
those questions and even questions some
of those assumptions yourself it's it's
not easy right I did some professional
development once with a someone who said
that sort of anti-racism work it's like
going to the dentist right it's not one
and done you got a flash you got a brush
in between and every once in a while you
got to go in and get a deep cleaning so
um it's just it's something you have to
be conscious about and deliberate about
because if you're not then you just slip
into two bad habits and and old habits
yep no that's that's super helpful but I
ought to see yes it's not easy and it's
it's very nuanced there are some
questions in the these conversations go
so fast when we're expressing topics but
there are some definitely some questions
let's see marshmellow from YouTube is
asking and maybe we can you know broaden
this how will co vid evolution eyes
learning I don't think we will be very
normal very soon and what's the new
normal so I guess you know maybe to
paraphrase this question there's a stuff
that you're doing in the immediate term
to you know make sure that everything is
working so to speak in back to school
but how do you think this is going to
change education
at KLS maybe in a more permanent way
even post kovat or or what implications
you think it might have broadly you know
well beyond KL Essen in the system as a
whole and maybe I'll even add you know
what's going on with the protests and
black lives matter do you think that's
also going to have some impact on
curricula or things like that but but
kovat it both of these things that are
going on in the world so I would say in
terms of what is coded doing I think
it's shining a light on how unprepared
we are for change and I also think it
shines a light on how incredibly
creative teachers can be in a moment but
that calls for a lot of support and not
just putting a laptop or or an iPad and
a teacher's hand or a student's hand but
what kind of real training that's best
led by teachers and teachers who are
really excited about this kind of
teaching and that they can work with
their peer group and their colleagues I
also think all of this shines a light on
the fact that the teaching actually
should follow the student where they are
and so giving less weight to just how
long has a student sat in a class but
more what have they actually learned in
that class and is it okay for them to
take a little bit longer to make sure
they master the material then to make
sure that just you know things are
running on time and if you don't get it
too bad kid we have to move to the next
thing like is that the point
so at collapsable you know we always say
that we're we're here to educate and not
to sort and again I think the the
underlying belief that all students can
achieve at a really high level is
somewhat radical and there's there's
good research to say that when you're
able to combine mastery-based learning
where the goal for kids is to actually
understand the material versus
upgrade and you're able to do some kind
of one-on-one time not tutoring
necessarily but even sort of tools like
Khan Academy are incredible for kids to
shore up their skills that just the
achievement is incredible so I think I'm
really having belief in all kids and
allowing more space and time and I'd say
also there are probably millions of
parents across this nation who have a
deeper appreciation for teachers and
what they do because it's it's hard
whether you're teaching someone how to
read or whether you're teaching someone
about stars or something like that it's
all it's all really difficult and it's
about making sure that the motivation
for students is is internal because
there we do a lot of hoop jumping I
think these days
ya know completely agree in you know my
own take is exactly what you're saying
is I think there's a world where post
kovat the whole system you know this
hybrid environment we're in it is
actually it's making a lot of educators
a lot of systems have to think a little
bit more in the direction that that
y'all have already been thinking at kls
which is how do we give students more
agency but at the same time give them
constraints and accountability so that
they are able to and supports with with
teachers but you know rethinking okay is
lecture the best thing or is it better
for something that teacher time to be
more in small group focused
interventions or one-on-one sessions and
you know goal reflections and things
like that and and I have to say you know
I I've been bragging maybe more than I
should because obviously my name is
associated with the school so it
probably doesn't reflect well on me but
y'all have done an incredible job being
able to fluidly go between these you
know in person world and this you know
socially distance world that I think can
be a really good example for what could
be done done other places
so Rachel unfortunately we're all the
time I hopefully we can do this again
and in the near future because there's a
ton of questions that I didn't
I didn't even get to I I will just say
you know I get a London out of credit
for both Khan Academy and for Khan lab
school because of I guess there's a name
association but but Rachael is one of
the people in my life who has really you
know doing the real on-the-ground work
of driving this broader vision and this
broader mission forward and so I feel
very lucky to work with her not just as
the head of school of my children's
school which I do feel very fortunate
about but also you know really pushing
forward these ideas of what school could
be not just for the 200 students at kls
but what they could be for the you know
a billion and a half kids around around
the world one day so so thank you Rachel
for it for that sure thank you for
having it's a pleasure to to be your
child's head of school your children's
head of school next time we can talk
about synchronous versus asynchronous
learning I'm sure you got some of those
questions but I think it's a great time
for education and I think as a country
were poised to have some fundamental
change for the better of all of us
actually I not - you know we we have we
had a nice conclusion going but I since
you brought up asynchronous and
synchronous because there are several
questions about that how do you
structure I mean how are you thinking
about asynchronous and synchronous just
as I think initially when everyone had
to shelter in place the instinct was to
sort of take what you were doing in the
building and then just map it to an
online platform and it just it just
doesn't work even for the teachers the
students you have to move your body a
little bit so then the conversation is
what is great for students to be able to
do together what are the conversations
that they can have and then what are
those moments where they can actually do
some work on their own and it's actually
better for them to have some space for
flow and for deep syncing so for us we
are doing both from kindergarten all the
way through 12th grade and our our
teachers are in
credibly thoughtful and creative and
even when I look at sessions for the
kindergartners they're actually engaged
but I think part of it is that in those
moments they're being asked to interact
right it's not just our teachers talking
to them but they're asking them
questions they're asking the students to
work together and so that happens in
math classes English classes history
classes science classes so I think you
need both and I think just by virtue of
it being online it can't be as full of
day as we're used to students having
when they're in person just because they
need those those breaks but it doesn't
mean they're learning less if if the
system that you have in place works and
if anything it's it's teaching them
again those executive skills time
management planning that are really
gonna serve them beyond school no and
this is one of the areas you know one of
the dreams of kls is that it can it can
really work in symbiosis with Khan
Academy and you know one of the things
that I'm excited about exploring with
Rachel and the team at kls over the next
couple of months are you know a lot of
these practices that Rachel and the kls
team have developed can we help document
some of that because the whole world is
trying to answer these questions right
now and and so thanks Rachel and the
team for for really I think doing a
really amazing job right now and you
know then thanks for and thanks for
being guest right now Thanks thanks
Rachel so thanks everyone for joining as
you can see I'm unusually lucky in
getting people to show up for this thing
and having interesting conversations and
the time always seems to go a little bit
faster than I expect and my apologies to
all the questions that I did not get to
but I'm sure we'll be able to get Rachel
on in the future but for everyone
watching thanks for watching and I
remind you if you're in a position to do
so please think about donating to Khan
Academy but I will see you tomorrow
you